[Musique]
bienvenue à tous dans ce nouveau numéro
de pas fort nous avons beaucoup de
sujets à aborder on va essayer de savoir
ce que c'est que ce nouveau chemin que
vous devrez tracer le président de la
république on va savoir aussi s'il faut
déboulonner ou non des statuts on va
s'interroger sur les procès il ya des
procès qui sont faits à des ministres ou
à des responsables administratifs de
wood responsable administratif est ce
que il faut rechercher la responsabilité
des politiques en justice toute une
série donc de questions tout à fait
passionnante et pour en parler à mme
perdriau bonjour cette conseillère
régionale d'île de france afin de
régions de france achève une visite à
bonjour benoît patris vous êtes maître
de conférences à l'université de rouen
et à sciences po
benjamin abonnés dit alors bonjour je
suis ravi de vous accueillir vous êtes
juriste et vous avez dirigé une étude
seulement passionnante qui paraît qui
paraît depuis quelques jours et qui
s'appelle le retour des corps
intermédiaires alors c'est un livre avec
beaucoup de de participation il ya
notamment françois hollande a dit
l'ancien premier ministre des juristes
existe rien on va en parler évidemment
tout à l'heure parce que le problème des
corps intermédiaires est au centre des
débats jean baptiste du club bonjour
vous avez dû classer du caire après tout
vous êtes de conférences à l'université
de versailles saint quentin et
jean-pierre de la vni bon je vous êtes
éditeur éditions la joie ni et vous
sortez actuellement un livre qui paraît
en poche c'est plus nouveau polar que
vous publiez
c'est pas la question savez vous le
montre l'étude tout juste sorti de
l'imprimerie
c'était le début dans le début de
collection de livres de poche donc très
près pareil on va commencer par cet
évènement c'est-à-dire s'arrêter là
évidemment l'intervention du président
de la république c'était hier
assez frappant je crois qu'ils aient eu
plus de 20 millions de téléspectateurs
c'est à dire que on est dans une période
où l'on conteste beaucoup l'état et en
même temps on attend la part à l'apport
de l'état
ça vous a pas frappés sainte germaine
simi c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup attendu
on a beaucoup glosé aussi sur cette
intervention présidentielle c'était
l'une de celles que l'on entendait le
plus peut-être parce que c'était la
première de la pseudo sortie du venus et
on est une sentiment qu'ils allaient
nous annoncer un changement de cap
politique peut-être même des éléments de
démission de destitution personnel etc
et au finish on se retrouve avec une
annonce très j'avoue dire très politique
finalement on a la continuité d'un
mandat des éléments programmes qui sont
détaillés est vrai qu'on a attendu
bizarrement plus il y as d'attentes lui
il ya deux déceptions aussi c'est
toujours un petit peu le risque avec la
parole présidentielle
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'en début de
mandat il maniait makuhari venu faire
très rare parce que c'est qu'on peut
parler c'est s'exposer aussi surtout
quand c'est ce discours sert
essentiellement à présenter les projets
politiques comme il l'a fait dimanche
alors voir venir après sur le fond mais
sur la forme de les uns et les autres de
ne pas briller vous l'avez trouvé plutôt
bon ou pas alors moi j'essaye toujours
de distinguer en fait sur le discours
est particulièrement ceux du président
de la république où s'arrête la com et
où commence l'action a fait c'est un peu
alors je dirais que sur l'action
la principale action pour lui ça a été
de reprendre la main en faisant des
annonces extrêmement concrètes et
pragmatiques donc ça c'est de l'action
c'est du concret et puis concernant
bella comme c'était peut-être essayer de
de convaincre l'opinion de sa volonté
d'un énième
changement de méthode voilà on va venir
après sur ce chemin bétonné sur cette
méthode
benjamin lebeau délits sur la forme
alors sur la forme je remarque qu'en
général les journalistes attendent
souvent des mots du président alors que
pour ceux qui m'intéressent noir je
l'attends beaucoup plus si je puis dire
dans les modes d'action donc ce que j'ai
noté mois dans les annonces qui n'a pas
forcément encore été très relevé
c'est l'idée du recours aux corps
intermédiaires ce qui pour moi est une
révolution est nu c'est le président de
la république qui jusque là s'est
dressée j'allais lire seul dans un
modèle je dirais subitement bur de ce
qu'est la république normalement dans
les principes dans ses fondations
céderait ses seuls face à chaque
français est assemblé redécouvrir à la
faveur de cette crise dramatique de
windsor coup du volet sanitaire et bien
que les français engagés existent et ont
des réponses à apporter sont autant de
points d'appui pour actionner sa
politique sur lesquels s'appuyer pour
diffuser ferveur réussir sa politique en
faveur la cohésion sociale qui sera le
vrai sujet à venir avec les volets
sanitaires économiques et et autres
qu'on va connaître bientôt
malheureusement alors peut-être qu'on va
passer avant que nos jean baptiste et
son charme sur le sur la forme latente
des français etc vous avez vous avez une
commentaires ajoutés sur la forme j'ai
trouvé qu'ils avaient presque 2 macron y
avait un maquereau que j'aime pas trop
qui lit presque au niveau d'un
sous-secrétaire d'état qui va presque
nous expliquer comment on va d infecter
un point crayon dans une maternelle et
ça je pensais pas le rôle d'un président
de la république mais en revanche s'il
devient vraiment les redevient président
le président que quand on aime un des
présidents qui fait son seul qui fait le
job quand il annonce par exemple qu'on
va pas déboulonner les statues kavala il
prend une véritable décision politique
et il est là où moi je l'attends en tout
cas voilà donc ce quand il est président
c'est très bien quand il est sous ce
côté un débat au désinfectant je laime -
mais voilà ces gels et militaires
baptiste est claire oui simplement en
quelques mots moi je trouve qu'on a en
faisant cas à un doute considérations
politiques un président un public qui
est extrêmement un conjoint extrêmement
brillant un pack chose que peut-être
deux cadres étaient des coûts de palier
en revanche sur la forme je joue j'ai
toujours trouvé que le prenne notre
présent la république étaient plutôt
mauvais dans les discours je crois que
il incarne pas atteint ses discours on a
l'impression qu'ils récit qui lit son
prompteur
donc je joue voilà pas de 17 jeunes
anglais c'est vrai que c'est quelque
chose auquel cas moi je suis plutôt
regarder les glaces est compliqué alors
on va peut-être passer sur le sur le
fond on ne peut pas il vers l'événement
va aborder toutes les questions
notamment les questions économiques mais
il ya quelque chose et peut-être que
bains savoie la voie d une fille ça vous
a parlé d'abord cette idée que bah tout
ne peut pas se décider à paris qu' il
faut faire confiance
sans doute aux élus sans notre région
sans doute aux villes sans doute au
département et et c'est une des résidus
c'est l'une des leçons d'ailleurs qu'on
a peut-être tiré de la crise de l'aco
vide notamment
oui mon point de vue en la crise de la
vie nous a donné deux leçons
la première vous m'entendez bien et bien
oui
la première c'est que les français
avaient certainement perdu le sens du
collectif au sens de vivre
collectivement quelque chose en dehors
une coupe du monde de football tous les
catholiques 4 ou 8 ans rappelle aussi
les français restent vraiment perdu la
vie collective d'un événement et un
malheureusement c'est un événement
dramatique qu'on ne vienne pas verser et
qui a prouvé qu'on avait besoin du
collectif dans l'après-coup vide pendant
le produit de bien sûr et la deuxième
chose la deuxième enseignement pour moi
est vraiment tellement c'est que l'on
mais sortir en quelque sort du mythe de
l'état lance à rejoindre le sujet de
l'étape qui pourrait tout faire
l'état ne peut pas tout faire et l'état
a besoin de la société civile un peu le
sens de l'initiative qui est la mienne à
travers l'institut américain
l'observatoire français les temps
intermédiaires et ses études longues et
à se réparer un père brio je disais vous
êtes élu régional vous êtes au conseil
régional d'île de france
on a vu pendant la crise justement que
les conseils régionaux comme les
concepts épartement tôt que les maires
ont pris des initiatives parfois à côté
d'état parfois outre l'état qui était
souvent paralysé par un pas une
administration très prenante
est-ce que vous justement vous avez vous
sentez un besoin de décentralisation
forte dans ce pays
alors c'est vrai que cette crise
sanitaire avec est vraiment le
révélateur de l'efficacité des
collectivités territoriales est
particulièrement vous l'avez vu dans les
médias la région et les communes sommes
les partenaires ont participé mais le
est ce exact
on a vu l' inertie alors que la région
avait déjà c'est 20 millions des 30
millions de masques livré sur le tarmac
l'état n'était pas encore livré et donc
c'est vrai que la région a pu dès les
premiers jours c'est à dire que dès la
première semaine
concernés c'est-à-dire la semaine du 17
mars distribué des masques aux soignants
aux hôpitaux aux communes pour tous les
publics prioritaires et là c'est vrai
que en lien avec les élus locaux
et là on a vu combien l'échelon local a
été essentielle à la bonne gestion de
crise
sachant que de toute façon la proximité
a toujours été plébiscité on sait que
les maires sont les et les bruits des
français et un journalisme on connaît
bien content ça c'est à dire plus mais
ses proches plus ça intéresse et plus
les gens se semblent concernés et donc
on a retrouvé tout où ce phénomène de
pragmatisme et d'efficacité à l'échelon
local des collectivités territoriales un
jardin de jeu des passes sur le sur la
décentralisation et les grandes lois
sous françois mitterrand les lois
defferre
mais c'est un débat très anciens au fond
est-ce qu'il faut avoir un état jacobin
pas et on a l'impression qu'on en parle
à chaque fois mais qu'on ne fait pas
grand chose et que quand même le réflexe
français c'est toujours de tout remonter
un pari à l'état c'est vrai et je bois
même dit que je ne pense pas qu'on ne
suis pas grand chose à la vérité depuis
les lois defferre qu'on a appelée l'acte
1 de la décentralisation
si on devait dénombrer le nombre des
droits compris chacun des présidents de
la vème république
on serait un acte simple vers la russie
de la décentralisation
donc moi j'ai le sentiment qu'au
contraire on a un espèce de vide
juridique bien remplie avec des noix qui
seront prises à chaque nouvelle majorité
et pourtant c'est un esprit qu'on
n'arrive pas à changer et je crois pas
que la france par un nouvel acte et
c'est pour ça que quand le président m'a
kron a parlé de donner plus de
responsabilités et de plus de lillers et
aux territoires
moi je crois pas nécessairement tssa
doivent passer par une nouvelle loi de
décentralisation d'ailleurs pas très
ciblés dans son escroquerie ce qu'on
entend dans les territoires les
associations les hôpitaux les
universités tous les plans et aux médias
justement sont un peu cité dans une
espèce de liste dans son discours je ne
sais pas exactement si ça doit passer
par une nouvelle manière de virer la
décentralisation c'est c'est finalement
la gouvernance de l'état qui doit
elle-même changer si c'est les outils de
la décision qui doivent être vus
différemment voire même
être la décision des manuels mcrib parce
qu'il faut le savoir
c'est un président qui a toujours voulu
incarner sa fonction et incarner une
véritable centralité de la décision donc
est ce que finalement ce n'est pas une
remise en cause aussi de sa manière de
dundee qui nous aiderait à à aérer un
petit peu le système décisionnel plus
mais nouvelle réforme de la
décentralisation
parce que moi je crois qu'on réfléchit
jamais à la manière vont changer le
système central - plus qu'à la manière
de l'objectif de liberté aux
collectivités ces nuits qui doit se
réformer à mon sens mais c'est à l'étagé
réforme et je me changeais jean baptiste
sur ce sujet la décentalisation
décentralisation il ya une a sûrement
besoin et qu'il ya du soleil
administratif ou ou plus haut et ados
plus haut niveau de l'état c'est une
certitude
après il faut se méfier de de tout
mouvement de balancier parce que quand
on voit notamment comment beaucoup de
mer où il n'y a pas d'autre mot saloper
la france en distribuant des permis de
construire sont sans le moindre regard
sur ce que c'est les données les
villages les villes etc
on voit que de temps en temps la dcc pas
parfait donc voilà c'est très bien peut
être qu'ils puissent commander des
masques voilà il faut pas non plus
donner trop de pouvoirs sans un regard
parce que c'est un petit peu ce qui nous
protège qui protège le le pays contre
des énormités qui pourraient être
commises dans une certaine urgence ou
une pression populaire parce que bien
évidemment je verrai un
haut-fonctionnaire un ministère la
pression populaire il sait même pas ce
que c'est et c'est d'ailleurs un peu
dommage mais de temps en temps ça peut
nous garantir que quand même d'éviter
quelques quelques énormités quelques
catastrophes qui sont quand même assez
importante sur les deux sont nécessaires
comment tu le monde les deux journées
c'est un cadre c'est lé cas oui mais les
particularités d'adaptation situation
c'est c'est l'échelon des vélos peau et
on a vu que dans la crise c'est en effet
les échelons locaux qu'ils étaient les
lieux comme
aujourd'hui de jérôme fouquet pour
dégripper la machine bassam el abdelli
sur ce sujet oui bah je souscrive est
totalement aux propos d'anne charlene je
ne pense pas que pour les besoins d'un
langage du personnel mais qu'on ait
besoin d'un acte x décentralisation au
contraire je pense qu'on a besoin de
réformer l'état l'état central au sens
de la pratique du pouvoir ce qui marche
localement que vous soyez tous très bien
ce qu'il marque autour d'une table de
comtés unis si pâle et c'est d'avoir des
gens qui sont en prise directe avec le
terrain je crois que ce qui pèche dans
la méthodologie d'action du gouvernement
c'est de ne pas être vraiment en prise
avec le terrain et d'avoir auront très
peu d'élus locaux parmi nos ministres
donc je pense qu autour de la table du
conseil des ministres
puisqu'on nous annonce un remaniement il
serait même le président macro serait
évidemment alizés de est bien beau
s'entourer de personnalités en prise
avec le réel des français tout
simplement
et évidemment vous en avez pour ma
chapelle dans les personnalités en gaz
et de terrain autour des tables des
conseil municipal local vous avez nommé
rappelé aux ors et le président d'une
association le même temps à la sécurité
est par exemple un ancien commissaire de
police sont des gens qui ont été en plus
avec le concret vient pas seulement des
faux escrita bien formés très
intelligent évidemment dans ma font les
gens qui connaissent la règle des
dépenses alors justement on veut dire
peut-être ce livre sur le retour des
corps intermédiaires parce que dans il
ya une conclusion dans ce livre de
françois hollande qui dit au fond le
grand problème que traverse la
démocratie aujourd'hui c'est la
désaffection des citoyens c'est leur
manque de confiance vis-à-vis des élus
c'est c'est au fond tout c'est
l'abstention évidemment sur le plan
politique et dit il avec les causes de
cette désaffection de 7
c'est principalement la fatigue des
corps intermédiaires
alors justement qu'est ce que c'est les
corps intermédiaires qui sont les causes
dire qu'est ce qu'on peut donner une
définition de ce que sont les corps
intermédiaires alors en philosophie
politique elle est très large et ce
qu'ils ont tous les bas toutes les
institutions associations fondations
chambre de commerce syndicats
fédérations patronales les think tanks
les ong
toutes les institutions qui permettent
finalement de jouer un rôle de tampon de
relais entre l'état central d'une part
et les citoyens d'autre part donc ne
s'agit pas de ramener ça ce qui est
souvent le cas de nos énarques de la
formation à l'ena qui est de dire que
finalement les corps intermédiaires
bref pour leur chapelle ou lorsque la
terex ma conviction tricks les gens qui
s'engagent le pont pour quelque chose
d'un peu plus grand que et que pour peu
qu'on se sépare de la peine de les
écouter on comprendra par exemple la
fédération des fromagers de france ne se
bat pas que pour l'intérêt des magasins
le fromage en france mais aussi pour la
culture française gastronomique
je suis vous prenez la région ile de
france madame brio l'association des
vous qui mise des quais de la seine à
paris ne se bat pas pour les 300
voitures hertz mais se bat aussi pour
une certaine image de paris est ce que
je vous dis là est évident dans les
associations pour les personnes âgées
on ne se bat pas pour les adhérents on
ne se bat pas pour l'intéressement de
ses membres lorsque vous venez dans un
café une structure on se bat pour la
petite part d'intérêt général fait
chacun doit avoir le service des eaux et
justement jean baptiste du cercle du
club sûr il ya ces faits que 2010 une
tentative d'une tentation en tout cas
des gouvernants avec cette démocratie
moderne d'aller directement du chef de
l'état jusque jusqu'au peuple sans
passer par ces corps intermédiaires
c'est vrai qu'on les a la panique on les
a délaissée depuis quelques années pour
les intéressés et à raison je crois
parce que si on regarde notre histoire
institutionnels
ce sont justement les partis politiques
qui ont fait du tort et du mal en soi un
parti politique était pas mal de
mocratique d'un sac mais la difficulté
est que les parties se sont multipliés
et qu'ils ont créé des systèmes
d'arrangement qui faisait que les
français que le général de gaulle a
souhaité qu un renforcement de
l'exécutif interviennent à travers
notamment l'élection du présent pour
créer une relation directe entre le pop
justement le secondera public c'était
une manière de lire tous les partis
l'interface certaine manière empêcher
comment dirais-je la démocratie alors
c'est peut-être aussi ce qui explique
que pendant souffre aujourd'hui c'est à
dire qu'on a un exécutif qui est fort
c'est effectivement de donner plus
d'importance au rpt au pouvoir
parlementaire une volonté quand j'étais
français d'intervenir il ya deux heures
de débat on les voit partout tout le
monde a une opinion sur tout et on
al'impression fous qu'eux ils sont pas
voir que quelques que c'est l'état qui
décide tout mais alors encore une fois
moi je me méfie quand même beaucoup
parce qu'il ya près de les dire une
sorte de 2 2 tentation gilet jaune quoi
à dire que batou toute opinion est bonne
à exprimer et toute opinion est
intéressante banon je veux ce rebond dit
que le fait qu' on a besoin d'experts on
a besoin de gens qui auraient fait des
études on a besoin des gens qui
connaissent les choses on peut pas comme
ça décidé se lever le matin en disant
mais moi je sais comment il faut gérer
la crise du corona virus
je sais comment il faut qu'on soit un
autoroute c'est non c'est pas vrai tout
le monde ne sait pas on a besoin
d'experts et se satisfait de coup de
balai intellectuelle qu'il faut cliquer
sur un lien on a besoin que ça remonte
du terrain mais je n'ai pas besoin des
filets jaunes pour me dire comment on
doit gérer la france c'est attention à
ça moi je veux dire il ya des gens qui
ont fait des dégâts
en a plein ici autour de nous qui sont
profs de fac et bah tant mieux
ils ont cette expertise quand on parle
de droit c'était à eux je m'adresse j'ai
pas envie que ce soit le premier pékin
venus qui me disent qu'il faut penser de
la justice etc
c'est pas attention à ça à se dire voilà
qu'est ce que c'est que ce ce retour ce
coup de balai d'arrondi maintenant les
gens qui savent serait pas les gens qui
devrait diriger b6 au rangement qu'on
essaie de france pour les meilleurs et
qu'on essaye de croyez gens qui seront
capables d'avoir une expertise d'avoir
une culture politique une culture
scientifique une culture juridique
sécuritaire important mais méfions-nous
c'est ce ce populisme intellectuelle
c'est qui qui voudrait dire que que tout
que tout le monde a la même valeur
intellectuelle mais non non non et hélas
c'est de demander un régional du clair
les corps intermédiaires c'est pas les
gilet jaune c'est parce c'est pas que je
ne disais pas les siens mais si on nous
de 2,2 ce coup de balai poste gis
déjouer consiste à dire bon ben voilà
dans cette interview le mauvais on le
sait justement les intermédiaires entre
le pouvoir et les français alors qu'ils
prennent comme le disait madame à
l'abonné dit tout à l'heure
beaucoup de formes ça peut être ça peut
être des associations ça peut être des
fondations ça fait des think tanks
s'appelle beaucoup de choses b et c'est
vrai que est ce qu'on a besoin d'un
challenge en fait dans tout ce qui a été
dit gagne à des réalités contradictoires
mais qui sont ils sont toutes là c'est à
dire que les corps intermédiaires qui
les a longtemps
et vanté notamment pendant la période
révolutionnaire et un peu après mais
pendant avec toute la période du
socialisme municipal où les communes ont
mis vraiment des capacités d'initiatives
qui ont permis à la france d'être ce
qu'elle est aujourd'hui
mais c'est vrai qu'on a ensuite dénoncé
un esprit corporatiste en france et
qu'on a le sentiment notamment quand on
pense au nombre de niches fiscales ou
non de petits avantages que chacun
essaye de préserver
on avait vraiment que nous vivons dans
un pays avec un esprit de clocher c'est
à dire avec cette idée que chacun veut
garder ce qui est petit prérogatives et
c'est notamment pour serrer seconde
qu'on a souhaité un peu alors plus
direct un conte le politique et le
citoyen néanmoins je crois que ces
intérêts ne propose pas c'est à dire que
comme le disait monsieur la polémique
tout à l'heure là les corps
intermédiaires
c'est une esprit d'institutions on a un
grand auteur qui s'appelle maurice
hauriou endroit qu'on vénère un peu et
qui est celui qui justement a parlé de
l'esprit d'institutions et l'esprit
d'institutions c'est cet esprit
collectif qui peut finalement s'exprimer
à n'importe quelle échelle et et moi je
crois que pour le coup ça fait aussi
notre faiblesse dans le sens où du coup
il y a beaucoup de petites cliques nous
entendons préserver donc ça fait notre
force et est même maintenant a peut-être
oublié un temps cela en prétendant être
un peu ce président jupitérien qui était
au ministère mais au moins là encore je
crois pas qu'on ait forcément besoin de
l'état central pour consacrer ces corps
intermédiaires à mon avis ils sont bien
présents en france et je pense qu'on a
besoin de leur ancrage de là à savoir si
ça suscite une nécessité pour l'état de
les reconnaître ou de leur donner encore
plus de pouvoir je ne suis pas sûr parce
que comme on disait tout est question de
balance l'état c'est le cadre et les
corps intermédiaires évidemment doivent
s'épanouir à l'intérieur comme on disait
avec leur milieu tout à l'heure sur le
meta qui va fixer la grande ligue et les
charlots quoi qui va venir
particulariser rendre plus proche de
nous les réalités benjamin lapeyre brio
le témoignage de quelqu'un qui est sur
le terrain qui est qu'une élite 2
terrain à qui vous avez affaire
justement les associations les ces corps
intermédiaires c'est important quand on
quand on en décision que doit prendre
des décisions de les consulter de savoir
un peu ce que ce que pensent les gens
tout à fait tout à fait là c'est vrai
que moi j'ai toujours été surprise alors
qu'on a comme on l'a dit un président
d'une grande intelligence que je pense
que c'est son manque d'expérience pour
le coup qu'il est toujours négligé ces
corps intermédiaires et je reviendrai 1
1 à la fin
un constat en communication vous savez
on parle toujours de cette fameuse
pyramide de la communication on peut
parler de la population au chef de les
faire directement
donc il ya une pyramide et 7 pyramidale
est composé de plusieurs strates
il ya en effet la population les corps
intermédiaires
on va retrouver tout ce que disait
benjamin les entreprises les
associations les syndicats etc
les élus locaux la strate voilà et le
président et je pense que on ne peut pas
faire fi de ces quelques strates qui
justement ont la volonté de ramener
l'expérience de terrain aux experts
comme le disait tout à l'heure jean
charles et quand rien les deux sont
antinomiques est opposé au contraire
tout le monde a besoin de tout le monde
et cette pyramide est extrêmement image
et pour montrer que les corps
intermédiaires sont un échelon
absolument incontournable je pense et
tant sa voix supplémentaires
justement alors le des problèmes on voit
bien comment comment la société
française est divisée on l'a vu avec
gilet jaune
on le voit encore encore aujourd'hui il
ya un vrai problème au pied quand on
parlait tout à l'heure à la
décentralisation c'est une façon aussi
décidé de recréer de la démocratie ya un
problème du contrat social en france
il faut nier qu'il faut d'ailleurs vous
de l'aborder dans le dans ce livre m'a
jamais la bonne et comment recréer ce
contrat social alors pour moi il s'agit
plus de le régénérer au sens où
je n'ai pas de postures idéologiques je
veux dire des avis des corps
intermédiaires
c'est une approche très concrète et
pragmatique j'ai été avant d'écrire ce
livre avec lou l'avait noté une
trentaine de personnalités politiques de
tout combat j'ai rencontré près de 400
personnes engagées de terrain et ce
qu'il en ressort c'est qu'il ya un
extraordinaire contraste entre un
maillage d'actions de terrain fabuleux
que connaissent bien les élus locaux les
acteurs de terrain ne sont plus
aujourd'hui reçu ou écouter au niveau
central
donc il ne s'agit pas de dire qu'il faut
plus les valoriser l'unc inscrire des
textes de loi ou autre pour ceux ci ce
n'est pas forcément ça l'enjeu c'est de
redonner la parole aux gens qui ont des
choses à dire c'est ce qu'on dit c'est
monsieur lawani tout à l'heure les
filets jaunes dans leur colère ont
montré qu'on avait besoin
d'interlocuteurs lorsqu'on est des
personnes publiques apolitique et qu'on
avait pas d'organisation permettant
d'avoir des interlocuteurs chez les
gilets jaunes
de la même manière la faire faire au
moment de l' incendie de rana 110 pardon
de du feu de notre dame a montré que
cette ferveur a besoin d'être canalisé
organiser tout ça passera des fondations
des associations ils reçoivent l'argent
qu'ils vont aider les grandes peurs
n'est due qu'au vides ont bien montré
l'importance des collectifs de médecins
des alliances de professionnels de la
santé
il n'y avait qu'à voir d'ailleurs
comment une journaliste composent leurs
plateaux de télévision bien souvent avec
des patrons de syndicats fédérations de
santé oms
on a un besoin d'organisation dans la
société qui a simplement besoin d'être
écoutés d'où mon initiative si je prédis
d'accord voilà de cette initiative
elle tiendra une session de ce contrat
social on voit bien quand même que et
comment comment comment essayer de
répondre ses divisions de la société
est ce que vous voyez ce qu'il peut y
avoir une réponse politique oh oui je
crois que justement il n'y avait trop
vite hic est que le haut mais le
discours présidentiel normalement elles
censées servir ainsi
l'unité est le vôtre et la vème
république par le président de la
république qui est justement cette part
mis trop de la nation c'est l'article 5
de notre constitution pour 10 et je
crois que justement cette idée d'opposer
certaines catégories une certaine classe
de français ont certes tout population
et est assez dangereuse et le discours
présidentiel à mon avis et 106 justement
renouer avec cette idée de l'unité alors
personnellement j'en attendais un petit
peu plus du discours de dimanche parce
que il ya eu un petit paragraphe on va
dire de son discours qui a été relative
à la non discrimination et opéra mais je
pense qu'il n'a peut-être pas assez
insisté sur le fait d'être français est
un maître un peuple uni quelque chose
qu'il avait pourtant bien fait sur les
premiers discours en période de les
catastrophes sanitaires et et et ses
vrais bleus ne cherchez pas à tendance à
accentuer en général le 1800 dans les
périodes troubles mais l'oubli un petit
peu trop facilement dans les périodes où
les choses vont mieux non moi je crois
que c'est le rôle du politique de nous
unir et qui ne faut vraiment pas quel
parti politique tombe dans dans la
culture personnelle et dans la dans la
guérilla
c'est un peu trop malheureusement ce que
l'on voit avec l'absence de culture
d'opposition que nous avons en france
l'opposition n'est jamais constructive
on pense beaucoup à la critique mais
plus jamais à la construction de quelque
chose alternatif et je pense qu'on a pu
voir le lac né de cet épisode là avec
l'attitude du groupe la france insoumise
pendant la réforme des traités c'est
dangereux que notre démocratie on en
arrive à une démocratie de
l'affrontement
c'est vrai que oui bah on pense que les
partis politiques pour souvent aux
échéances futures
en tout cas vous avez assisté à des
élections municipales il
est ce que est ce que vous avez
l'impression quand même que la france et
nous l'opinion française est plus divisé
que jamais alors oui alors on le ressent
effectivement c'est ce qui inquiète un
peu les français d'ailleurs et alors je
reprendrai ce qu'a dit jean charles tout
à l'heure c'est à dire que le discours
du président en fait on a eu
l'impression qu'il a fait le grand écart
entre le secrétaire d'état et le
président de la république et c'est pour
ça que comme le disait allez charlène le
message un peu plus solennel du contrat
social avec le peuple français
en fait il n'a pas pu avoir la force
qu'il aurait pu ou qu'il aurait dû avoir
parce qu'il a démarré son disco part du
pratico-pratique en fait est de démarrer
son speech avec du pratico pratique on a
eu du mal à prêt à raccrocher sur le
front de la hauteur et voilà qui
délivrait un message mes bébés en même
temps je pense que les français
attendaient de savoir le dcu fine pour
les zones vertes et c'est à moi qu'ils
avaient eux aussi ont envie de voir ça y
est c'est vrai que malheureusement
windows c'est pas aux c'est peu dire la
république en principe de non c'est ça
je dois vous avez raison là dessus il ya
évidemment 1-1 1-1 des démarques de ses
divisions dont on parle et c'est la
lecture de l'histoire c'est de savoir
s'il faut qu'on lui dit et d'histoire il
faut déboulonner comme on dit et des
statuts essayer de monter très forte là
dessus at elle d'ailleurs faut-il le
fait de pressions publiques a dit non on
ne va pas réécrire l'histoire on va pas
de dépôts donné des statuts qu'est ce
que vous en pensez à ce qu'après tout on
peut pas en un peuple qui est fort un
peu appliquée sur de lune pourrait pas
revisiter des moments de son histoire
il veut répondre à cette question moi je
suis totalement opposé à cette idée de
de gaulle territoire parce que le jeu
les souvenirs que nous en avons
mon avis il y en a qu'un seul c'est le
souvenir de toutes les dictatures et les
régimes n'ont d'ailleurs c'est franck ou
qui a fait ça mussolini
constantia clou en ton choix denis dans
l'histoire on la romance et finalement
on en fait une histoire qui n'est pas
l'histoire je crois que ce qui distingue
l'histoire avec un grand avantage de
l'histoire avec un petite histoire c'est
c'est la vérité mais si on commence à
choisir dans la vérité moi c'est ce que
vous détestez dans cette fois fightnews
c'est que pour moi la politique la
justice le droit n'ont pas à se
préoccuper de la vérité et de le pouvoir
ce qui fait la force d'un peuple c'est
d'accepter ou les épisodes de son
histoire et il y avait des grands hommes
qui ont vécu dans des périodes qui ne
sont pas les nôtres
bon moi réinterpréter la révolution
française à l'aune de ce que nous vivons
à 2020 ça me parlait très triste et très
réduit je crois qu'il faut aussi
démontré que on a vécu dans des époques
où les réalités était différente et nous
sommes aptes à comprendre c'est très
dangereux de réécrire donc ce que ça
signifie aussi qu'on peut s'approprier
une vérité pour l'arranger à notre
manière et comme ça complètement
dangereux pour l'histoire d'un peuple et
pour son ancrage dans la réalité je veux
je fais une citation c'est une
excitation de de jean jaurès qui est
cité dans le poids par giesbert qui a
écrit voilà nous savons bien que la race
juive concentré passionnés subtil
toujours dévoré par une sorte de fièvre
de gains c'est jean jaurès alors
évidemment est ce que est ce qu'il faut
le problème qu'il de fond c'est celui-là
est ce qu'il faut juger avec nos yeux
d'aujourd'hui
des propos des attitudes qui était faite
avec des mentalités bière c'est ça le
fond du problème non jean baptiste
duquel je crois qu'on peut tout à fait
il a finement pas question d'interdire
de revisiter notre histoire si elle
revisite et ne se confond pas avec
révisionnisme
alors après sur des propos comme ceux
qui ont été tenus par changerait
effectivement ça montre la complexité de
l'homme était alors quelques stars et
que savons qu'il faut il faut distinguer
comment dirais-je l'homme de l'heure qui
a été accompli après fait des prêts
comment dirais-je visiter l'histoire
voir la revisiter ce n'est pas du
révisionnisme ça n'impose pas après deux
des bonnets des statuts déboulonné une
statue de la dir dans ce qu'elle a nié
une part de cette histoire on peut
maintenir nos statuts et approfondir la
connaissance qu'on a sur loeb
on a érigé dans le bar plutôt que de
déposer les statuts moi je serais plutôt
d'avis d'en rajouter d'ajouter de
nouvelles figures nouvelle stature ça me
paraîtrait plus adéquat avec nos wii
matrix non est-ce qu'on peut répondre
peut-être aussi en amoureux en amoureux
de l'art des beaux-arts et se dire que
finalement et je rejoins ce que vient de
dire notre ami à l'instant on pourrait
attendre aussi les princes qui nous
gouvernent aujourd'hui à la volonté
d'avoir bien eu le valoriser les gens
d'aujourd'hui les genres de pédiatrie
hier si je puis dire
mais les grandes figures arnaud on peut
quand même parce que ce moment-là rublee
remettre en cause
on peut aussi revisiter notre histoire
est peut-être que ce qu'on nous a appris
n'est pas totalement la vérité que ce
qu'on a appris d'ailleurs des ddd grand
personnage n'est pas totalement toute
leur vérité on peut provoquer quel est
le mal qui dit à dire la vérité sur tous
ces personnages là jean-charles
précédente question c'est que faut-il
déboulonner faute qui le réécrire
l'histoire
je pense que anne charlène parle d'or
elle a totalement raison
mais qu'après il suffit juste de voir
qui veut revisiter l'histoire qui veut
déboulonner les statues
quelle est la qualité tous ces gens là
on comprend tout de suite que c'est un
truc
enfin voila c'est à dire
la proposition de revisiter l'histoire
vient de gens qui veulent effectivement
s'en prendre à ce que peut être la
france l'histoire de france à ce qu'est
une certaine idée de la culture d'une
culture dans une démocratie avec
effectivement un passé que personne ne
nie qu'on peut étudier s'ils tentaient
que tous ces gens aient envie de faire
un petit peu d'histoire de se cultiver
un petit peu et d'aller au delà de leur
propre passion ou de leur propre
communautarisme et que et qui souvent ne
s'intéresse qu'à ça kaka leur propre
histoire de deux groupuscules de deux
groupes etc et c'est extrêmement dommage
la france c'est bien au delà de ça la
france comme je ne sais plus petite
était seule
c'est le choix que c'était à nous à
internet c'est avant tout un peuple le
peuple français il est pour moi
indivisible et c'est tout donc il n'y a
pas une histoire qu'on va où on va
donner un petit peu de pouvoirs à un tel
groupe at-elle groupes de pression que
ça avait l'air brûlant var visible et ah
oui c'est ce statut leur gala du blosne
et non il n'y a aucune raison d'éboulis
quoi que ce soit cultivez vous tous les
jours votre machine et apprenez
l'histoire
et puis voilà et après on en reparle
mais surtout pas de père brillant parce
que vous allez devoir justement de nous
quitter dans quelques instants
vous allez participer aux cérémonies
justement du 18 juin alors là on est
quand même dans l'évocation historique
on est aussi dans le roman national où
nous raconte une histoire on nous
raconte l'histoire de cette france qui
va résister qui est peut-être pas tout à
fait non plus la réalité de ce qui s'est
passé pendant quatre ans vous pensez que
c'est important justement d'avoir des
symboles comme ça qui nous réunissent
dans l'histoire tout à fait moi je suis
prêt
alors là on part d'un appel
ar oui l'appel du général de gaulle est
donc la ccph actuels 1 mais c'est vrai
que je trouve que autant on peut
revisiter un plat autant on ne visite
pas l'histoire
moi je suis vraiment très très très ça
fait mal ce débat actuel alors le débat
est intéressant mais justement un peuple
je pense doit la grandeur d'un peuple
c'est d'assumer son histoire et on ne
peut pas avec nos yeux d'aujourd'hui
réinterpréter l'histoire je suis
totalement d'accord avec les
interventions précédentes et par contre
je pense que ce qui est intéressant
c'est de faire de la pédagogie et
quitter une histoire et d'en profiter
pour faire de la pédagogie avoir des
mais en aucun cas revoir l'histoire et
c'est vrai que parmi les événements que
que nous avons l'habitude de commémorer
je trouve que le 18 juin c'est pour ça
que j'étais absolument c'est cette une
c'est une cérémonie patriotique plein
plein de symboles de symbole extrêmement
fort et c'est certainement
c'est d'ailleurs alors malheureusement
là les contraintes sanitaires font que
nous serons très peu nombreux en général
c'est l'appel du 18 juin qui dans mon
environnement attire le plus de monde
l'événement les gens se se retrouve dans
ses racines et ses symbole très fort qui
sont portées par l'appel du 18 juin le
courage
voilà le courage dont on a tant besoin
mais aussi d'écriture de ce qu'on a pas
de routes nationales c'est dire que
voilà c'est l'année c'est l'exhortation
des valeurs de valeurs qui nous qui nous
plaisent des valeurs dans laquelle on
peut reconnaître qu'ils sont celles de
l'art du combat de la résistance du
courage
sap a toujours été la réalité de notre
histoire
je suis parvenu à faire venir je trouve
un peu dommage justement dans cette
tentative permanente de réécriture c'est
que un peuple qui ne sait même pas qui
passe son temps
alors là l'histoire était absolument
passionnante mais mais mais cette espèce
de d'autocritique permanent à chaque
fois de d'essayer de trouver quelque
chose qui va pas que
chose qui divise de trouver toujours là
de l'aspect négatif un peuple qui ne
s'aiment pas est un peu pineapp qui n'a
plus d'intérêt qui n'a plus de raison
d'être
alors il ne faut pas tomber là dedans
ouais exactement exactement et vous
verriez l'émotion les notions de du
public tout toutes les générations
confondues
quand on quand on se replonge dans ces
moments d'histoire extrêmement fort les
gens on a besoin de 116 1 et 2 et de
cadres comme on disait tout à l'heure
qui est très très très fort une chanson
mboma c'est que le la première c'est la
remarque le général de gaulle après la
période de 45 us à mon avis
l'intelligence des voix et façonné
l'histoire de la collaboration
le pacte constitutionnel notamment en
essayant de dire que ce qu'il n'avait
jamais existé
les très traumatiques n'avait pas existé
mais je connais mon intelligence
finalement de peut-être et qui une fois
mais non dans pour apaiser les tensions
et pour éviter ou les fins du wind camp
du non une france des collabos et des
résistants et alors qu'il a mené ce
mouvement il a réussi à essayer de nous
faire oublier ensuite pour montrer qu'on
était la france et qu'on n'en avait
jamais changé et la deuxième c'est la
chanson c'est jean jacques goldman c'est
né en 17 à leidenstadt où on se rend
compte que l'on ne peut parler
l'histoire est ce qu'on ne sait pas qui
on aurait été dans ces périodes là aussi
donc un peu d'humilité face à na on y
est facile de le vivre la vie que nous
vivons est d'avoir des points de vue
critique celle d'il ya cent ans
mais nous attendons un peu à la place de
nos aïeux pour savoir si on aurait fait
mieux que albert brio merci beaucoup je
vous dis vert pour que justement vous
puissiez aller cette manifestation
gratuite voire merci beaucoup
on va passer à un autre sujet qui me
c'est passionnant
vous avez vu que le premier ministre le
ministre de la santé le directeur de la
santé monsieur salomon sont poursuivis
en justice
soit par des associations par des
associations de médecins notamment sa
pause ça aussi un vrai problème
est-ce que vous peut être dans une
démocratie accompagnent ou vers nancy au
risque à chaque fois des poursuites
judiciaires sous prétexte qu on n'a pas
pris toutes les précautions du sage là
on va éviter l'année de la base de ces
poursuites c'est la mise en danger de
des personnes qu'il est jean baptiste
seckler patata tu roules effectivement
il faut il n'est pas pensable on puisse
exemptés nos responsables administratifs
et ses responsabilités au plan pénal
évidemment la crise crecque le savoir le
la justice pénale pour ces autorités
contenu dans l'or je crois que la
réponse est positive d'autant plus que
le niveau de rentabilité qui est à sud
est extrêmement important si on prend
nos élus nationaux
nos responsables nationaux il était donc
leur responsabilité étant extrêmement
importante qui n'est pas envisageable de
faire que les us que les justiciables
que le quidam puisse aisément mettre en
cause nos responsables pour une raison
simple c'est que ceci est bien
passeraient leur temps à se défendre des
quelques décisions qui seraient prises
et s'ils ne sont pas poursuivis craindre
et de prendre des décisions courageuses
tupper justement de se retrouver devant
la justice donc je crois qu'il faut être
prudent avec cela ceci étant dit alors
sur les infractions le qui peut-être au
tchad et reste à ma pratique pour
inaction face à la crise je crois que là
aussi le puisque des décisions l'édition
seront prises en fonction de
considérations de fait on s'y
rassemblent faits dont on parle c'est
une crise sanitaire dont
je le rappelle on ne connaissez
absolument peu de chose au moment de
s'abattre sur le pays
donc je crois qu'il faut prendre la
mesure de cela sont pour autant comment
dirais-je le frère que nous responsables
soient ne soit jamais inquiété je pense
que c'est bidon l'erreur manifeste des
rats brave we qui est que j la maison
n'a pas bon dire les choses simplement
un bis truc qui tue sa femme et vidéos
peuvent être poursuivis là il s'agit de
deux poursuites pour des décisions
politiques sont prises et il d'ailleurs
jérôme salomon qui a été entendue devant
la commission d'enquêté de l'assemblée
nationale
alors on dit cette phrase de voltaire
avant de savoir on ne sait pas si le
problème des ddd politique peut-être
jean-charles avec 2 micros qui peut qui
peut penser intelligemment et si elle
manque un homme politique de premier
plan comme un premier ministre alors il
se trouve que là c'était de voir
philippe mais ça pourrait être un
précédent à safra parlement le suivant
ces gens à ce niveau là qui peut penser
qu'un seul de ces hommes ou de ces
femmes peut délibérément faire le mal et
dire il ya une crise je vais prendre la
mauvaise décision je vais mettre la vie
des français en danger
c'est c'est la chose la plus grotesque
que j'ai jamais entendu c'est eux ça ne
devrait même pas pouvoir être aidées par
un être une pensée aussi stupide quoi
bien évidemment qu'il warcq et pippa
fait au mieux au mieux de ses capacités
au mieux de ces informations
et voilà il ne crée aucun reproche à lui
faire mais vous citez quand même un
extrait d'un article d'un journal que
vous connaissez bien qui s'appelle
marianne qui dit ceci face à une telle
tragédie la colère sera immense et face
à des milliers de plaintes pénales
venant de toute la france il faudra
rappeler aux corps des magistrats au nom
de qui ils doivent rendre justice et
ceux qui ont failli devront prendre des
comptes
ça s'est su le populisme lorsque sa
fille en face et c'est marianne dans ce
que sa plus mauvaise à venir c'est
enfourché n'importe quoi faire de là on
n'est même plus dans le débat que ça n'a
rien d'intellectuel sanaryens
d'intelligence et ses citoyens comme
argumentation
qu'est ce que c'est
ces phrases grotesque d emilie est plein
qui vont monter dudus du de la terre
enfin je dérange dans les pires heures
de la bêtise et d'histoire enfin je
comprends même pas aberrant mme
adjamagbo délit justement ces procès qui
sont faire des ministres où on prend du
ministre s'est pas encore une manque
peut-être de corps intermédiaires de
gens qu'ils puissent à qui on puisse se
référer d'aujourd'hui pu s'expliquer non
vous êtes gentil non non je ne pense pas
chacun doit répondre de ses actes et on
est vraiment là dans le régalien et
parce qu'il appartient le père lorsque
mon des listes président la république
qui doivent évidemment aux leurs actes
vous pensez que ne sont pas concernés
donc ce que vous dites vous après tout
il n'ya pas de raisons pas de pouvoir
poursuivre en justice
1 mission considère qu'il a pris une
mauvaise décision
là encore une fois c'est le la base
c'est la mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui
ah pardon oui non mais vous avez des
mines en praticien au quotidien du droit
plateau qui aura alors peut-être
peut-être jamais une visite éclair
juridique bout c'est compliqué à dire
mais est-ce que juridique vous pensez
que ça tient des poursuites contre des
dérives des ministres des responsables
comme comme comme salomon le directeur
de la santé sous le prétexte encore une
fois qu'ils ont mis en danger la vie
d'autrui
yahia il ya deux choses la première
c'est un petit mouvement on comprends
cette colère 1 de la part de la plupart
des citoyens qui ont entendu en est
incapable
mascate ans qui n'arrivait pas j'essaie
soignants qui changeait de communication
très facilement
donc il ya un instinct j'ai envie de
dire de résilience y passant quelles que
soient par le fait de chercher un
coupable
on a besoin pour se sortir complètement
de cette crise sanitaire de comprendre à
cause de qui nous avons des puces maman
trouve de votre histoire et on ne peut
pas mettre en cause
non de force majeure comme utilise
épidémique on a besoin qui miaule
logique excusez moi on en à responsable
physique et va chercher dans la personne
de nos gouvernants heureusement nous ne
sommes pas les seuls mitali les états
unis
tout le monde est en train aujourd'hui
politiquement d'essayer de répondre
presque pénalement
l'une responsabilités face à ce virus
néanmoins c'est cette deuxième réunion
réponse
juridiquement je ne suis pas sûr que ça
tienne dit parce que les éléments de
mise en danger de la vie d'autrui de
non-assistance à personne en danger il
ya beaucoup de trous fondement qui
seront choisies d'ailleurs dans les
plaintes on retrouve auprès de la cour
de justice
un coup c'est zé - là sont plutôt
normalement de nature à démontrer une
imposture
là je rejoins l'avis d'intention de la
part des politiques de ne pas protéger
la population et il est vu on a du mal à
imaginer comment berne on peut on
arriver à chemillé le daily mail man de
mettre en danger la vie d'autrui
donc c'est dans cet élément de la preuve
qu'on retrouve malheureusement
l'absurdité de ce type de recours c'est
que on a évidemment dans un besoin de
vengeance aux urgences et même un grand
mot mais un besoin de de punir les
responsables
néanmoins politiquement c'est un choix
entre plusieurs orientations qui peuvent
se discuter et je pense que la
commission d' enquête parlementaire et
peut-être le bon endroit pour cela mais
joue devant la justice au pénal
je ne crois pas qu'on soit devant un bon
cénacle il faudrait prouver qu'on avoue
étrangers c'était un peu dangereux
lacroix enfin juste rajouter un mot
c'est qu' il n'y a pas besoin de de
porter plainte un jugement nous sommes
dans une démocratie et des élections
dans un an et demi de l'élection
présidentielle
si le français pense qu'effectivement
l'état a failli que l'état s'est
effectivement emmanuel macron et edward
liddy ou un autre une autre si c'est le
remplace
il est des gaz ils ont qu'à voter c'est
ça le système dans une démocratie c'est
pas d'emmerdés en permanence d'encombrer
les délais des cours de justice
d'emmerder les hommes politiques etc
c'est à dire les sons
faire le boulot et après on vote ou
votre peau ou votre compte c'est le
meilleur jugement possible c'est tout il
est d'ailleurs on voit bien qu'il ya une
crise du politique et de personnalités
qui veulent s'engager en politique et je
pense que ce genre de faits pour
désengorger annales fait c'est presque
la fin de cette émission vous devez vous
interroger sur deux phrases l'accréditer
une france peut-être de manuel valls
aujourd'hui la guerre des races
remplacer de la lutte des classes qui
est ce que conforter cette phrase ce qui
est qu'ils aient beaucoup reproché
notamment par la gauche
moi je suis pas du tout d'accord parce
que je crois que l'on n'a
malheureusement encore les deux et que
ce soit libre de parler d'une minute ou
d'une autre c'est en effet une 1re que
notre n'aurait pas et là je crois que
précisément ces deux éléments comme
grille de lecture de l'histoire sont
très réducteur et que c'est un moment où
nous avons vécu ensemble justement
benjamin ne me disais tout à l'heure
cette crise au moins elle a ravivé les
dd ce qu'on a appelé les nouvelles
solidarités
c'est un peu tôt maintenant pour
directement s'affronter sur un nouveau
terrain rappelons que nous allons
définir il ya quelques mois ensemble
essayons de vivre ensemble 17 ans
d'abord il faudrait que les races
existent pour king et il ya peut-être
une autre phrase alors séquestré deux
hommes qui est raphaël enthoven c'est un
tweet mais qui noie moi c'est plus
marrant je vous la cites c'est quel
bonheur d'avoir connu le 20e siècle
comme je plains les enfants qui naissent
aujourd'hui et qu'il ne reconnut de
liberté que l'autocensure et des bons
sentiments
vous avez vu qu'on va peut-être un peu
revisitée autant en emporte le vent ou
en tout cas m ddd reconstitue
reconstituer lalalala l'époque
historique dans laquelle ça se passe
est ce que c'est de cette phrase moi ce
jeu je pense jamais c'est une phrase
absolument magnifique lequel à laquelle
je souscris totalement il a il a hélas
totalement raison et
c'est affolant sa salle augure des jours
mauvais effectivement là après on peut
quand même je modère un tout petit peu
en faisant confiance quand même à nos
enfants et la génération qui suit pour
se réinventer pour être plus
intelligente qu'on ne le pense
et pour faire fi de toutes ces
calembredaines actuel benjamin des
délits oui je veux dire bon on est à
rennes le 18 juin
oui une des grandes leçons du xxème
siècle c'est que malgré l'horreur
on a été capable comme français de se
rassembler autour d'un grand toc et des
générals de gaulle est ce que le dirai
c'est qu'il faut quand même pas
désespérer de notre jeunesse il ya des
études très précises qui montre pour en
revenir un peu et terminer sur mon sujet
aujourd'hui à l'engagement vous avez
dans les jeunes de terminale à nombre de
foyers un but de l'ordre de 50% de
mémoire de jeunes qui sont engagés dans
des ong vous dans des associations de
terrain et qui ont à coeur de porter un
message collectif où elle est une partie
de l'espoir de demain vient aussi ces
jeunes qui s'engagent jean baptiste
duclair conclusion c'est que nous
connaissons évidemment des mots au 21e
siècle il faut pas les beignets les si
on compare ce siècle naissant mon kiki
kiné constat liminaire bien sûr avec le
20e set
n'oublions pas aussi que il ya eu de
guerre mondiale celle de vichy
un grand père qui était dans les prisons
nazis donc il faut il faut moins
sollicités en temps de paix il sera même
pas dans une dictature
merci merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
voient jamais la bonne idée je rappelle
donc le retour des corps intermédiaires
commencé chez phone edition
c'est donc un rapport que vous avez une
étude que vous avez dirigé avec beaucoup
beaucoup de contributions d'anciens
premiers ministres président de la
république d'historiens de juristes
évidemment de politologues et c'est un
travail tout à fait passionnant merci
jean charles lajoie ni et d'orgueil on
peut se procurer
en poche de faire tous nos livres dans
toutes les bonnes librairies donc par
ferries merci bonjour baptiste déplaire
merci beaucoup a observé mme vézina duc
terre et à très vite on ne veut pas
j'espère
[Musique]